let a lot more pressing political stuff
a friend of George Clooney says
he might be jumping into the political
arena
we've got a quote he has big ambitions
and aims to get into politics
eminently he wants to do more
humanitarian work in hopes to join the
democrats 2016 election campaign
george's thinking about how he can get
more involved now he has a mile by his
side it will give him more credibility
to run for office a corset this is a
friend of George Clooney's
could he obviously is no stranger to
politics he helped Obama get reelected
in 2012 he does a lot of political
fundraising
he's been involved in Darfur for he's
also married British lawyer amala mood
in
and she defended WikiLeaks Julian
Assange agencies a human rights
specialist so obviously he has interests
that go beyond
just acting and the reason I wanted to
this story because of course this is
just conjecture and it's one friend the
thing that but
I'm a firm believer that the way
everything heading in this country we're
gonna just start
voting in celebrities I mean hilary is
already becoming more of a celebrity
than a politician
and Obama was sort of a a celebrity a
candidate I think that's the route is
going for better or worse
is ISAM net battered a good this this
celebrity
political mumbo jumbo think it depends
on the celebrity
but I think it's an issue when we take
someone for Lebanese status
or for for example under short shorts
mayors like machos
skilled and you know power in movies and
transferred over to the real world I
think that the issue when we assume
that these characters that the plan
television are actually part of who they
are
right so you want a torta de vere like
bust into the Capitol in Sacramento with
guide me there
big yeah yeah no
no I wanted him %uh flurries today yeah
I'm
but at different story I just think that
it kinda crazy how we
all about automatically attribute sort
of characteristics to celebrities and
assume that that to the I think that's
why people fall in love with celebrity
they don't realize that their
actors wreck so that's the part that i
think is really interesting about this
because if you look at when he looks
presidential right
people people like him he could play the
president are usually played a
presidential candidate
for where would we leave it was called
i'd the March
did not see that one this occurred at
the event make awake
Turner Classic Movies yeah would you
vote for honey
would you were coming home because on
one hand like
he seems like he's on the right side of
things pro-gay rights
he did a lot of work for Darfur before
anyone else dead the other hand even
might be a little bit of an Obama crummy
like
what happens when his idealism get kinda
question he surrounded by the people
that say you do this you do that and he
becomes a different man
the only thing is not strong enough I
mean
you work out more yeah about what I can
really funny about that quote was
it was kinda intimating like oh now he's
ready now that you don't have a wife
give the youth qualified right he's
getting this white so said only if you
have a white then obviously
call me you can be present just to
clarify what I think earlier I don't
think that the celebrity thing
and politics is good like that net good
in general but I do think there's maybe
like a little room where
having people that are already rich and
already popular
maybe would be a little more honest
because they wouldn't be beholden
to all the all the corporate interest
maybe maybe a little bit I know it's a
slippery slope into a bit as something
it sounds kinda gross
that up the politicians who started at
celebrities and one
were conservative so I'm going to I can
think I love are
al franken and well-made it was an
actually john was going to
the act so she did maybe if not the
worst thing in the world
yet do you guys think we need what they
have in most European countries
a president and a prime minister so one
the president that's where the celebrity
that has all the ceremonial stuff
and then a prime minister that actually
does what are present at like actually
does the work as I think that might help
if we were able to get some by the like
paparazzi stuff
of with the president and then have
someone else that was actually doing the
work to think that would help
I feel like that kinda happened already
I mean I don't assume that President
Obama's they're actually doing something
that you
I old day it now I kid but on
I feel like they probably and hot he
probably has a certain set of
responsibilities are
president does rain and then the other
day meet up right we don't think so much
of it is just going to the fundraiser
showing up at these events
as opposed to a work I think you agree
with me right don't like absolutely a
at the lot 1 percentage thing that they
already kinda to be a tearing it up
what he thinks we have a president and a
prime minister
and what are you are not a monarchy all
other than yeah
you know about allow it might be
I don't know about that I don't know
about that one day now now
now alright my crazy idea wanna turn
into a little more american alright I'm
not
okay